Now that we understand what the distribution is
we're going to go back to the mouse weights
where we created several differences of the means of two populations
under the null where we know there's no difference.
Those were created under the null hypothesis.
So I'm going to re-run that.
We should have that saved in our script file.
So we can just run those very quickly.
We're going to get 10,000 values under the null distribution.
10 differences between the two groups.
So we earlier found that that was a relatively rare occurrence
under the null-- the value that we see with our actual original data
where we did, in fact, feed the mice a high-fat diet.
Well, so let's now study the null distribution more carefully.
The distribution of those values we created
then, those 10,000 values we created, follow the normal distribution.
So again, look at that.
Let's make a histogram first.
All right, there it is.
It's centered at zero.
That's not surprising, because we created these values under the null.
There should be, on average, no difference.
We also see quite a bit of variability.
This is a random variable.
There's variability coming from just nature and random sampling.
So what else can we do here?
To study the distribution, we can make a q-q plot
to see if the prediction of the central limit theorem holds.
In other words, that this distribution is normal.
So we can do that using the qqnorm function in R and run that.
And we can see it looks like it is, in fact, following
a normal distribution pretty much to the dot.
So here we had an n of 12.
And in this particular case with this particular data,
that shows that the central limit theorem
is going to be quite useful for doing inference here,
for performing inference here.
So what we're going to do next is we're going
to look at some more examples of the central limit theorem
with this particular data set.